hello and welcome to med simplified
acidity or acid reflux disorder is a
very common problem
affecting more than 20 percent adults in
the western countries
acid reflux happens when the contents
from your stomach move up into your
esophagus
it is also known as acid regurgitation
or gastroesophageal reflux
acid reflux can cause an uncomfortable
burning feeling in your chest which can
radiate up towards your neck
this feeling is often known as heartburn
if you have acid reflux you might
develop a sore
or bitter taste at the back of your
mouth it can also cause you to
regenerate food or liquid from your
stomach
into your mouth in our previous videos
about acid reflux disorder we have
discussed in detail about why acidity
occurs how to treat it natural remedies
and diet for people with acid reflux
disorder
so make sure to watch these videos too
so you have a better understanding of
this problem
in this video we will discuss what are
the benefits of curd for people with
acidity
so let's begin acidity is caused when
the stomach starts
over producing gastric acid that instead
of helping in digestion of food causes
problems like
heartburn burning sensation in the
stomach and belching
now if you are suffering from these
symptoms consuming something spicy and
hard to digest
can exert stress on your digestive
system increasing your acidity and
reflux symptoms
curd is a dairy product obtained from
milk and milk has high amounts of
calcium in it
that prevents buildup of acid by
eliminating the excess amount
making it an efficient home remedy for
acidity
the ph of milk can range between 6 and 8
but the fermentation process reduces the
ph of curd to 4.3 or 4.4
lesser the ph more acidic the duration
of fermentation can make curd even more
acidic
now although curd is a technically high
acid food it is recommended for most
people as it has a soothing effect on
the stomach
now this is because curd is generally
considered to be less harmful
as it contains citrate and lactate which
are produced due to the fermentation
process
these along with the calcium present in
the curd help to neutralize the highly
acidic
hydrochloric acid or hcl that our
stomach produces
a study even showed that curd may cure
the infection caused by the bacteria h
pylori
which is the most common cause of
acidity due to stomach infections
also curd is a probiotic rich food which
helps the good bacteria in our gut to
grow properly
that are very important for healthy
digestion the best way to have curd is
to have it first thing on an empty
stomach
diluted with water you can eat it with
fruits
or even make curd rice start to include
curd in your daily diet it will
definitely make a difference in the
symptoms of facility
i hope i was able to answer the question
if you liked the video
make sure to share this video with your
family friends and any person you know
who might be suffering from acid reflux
you can support med simplified by
joining our channel here on youtube or
becoming a member at our patreon page
links are in the description below thank
you so much for watching and see you in
the next video